it was at the end of March that Dre
posted his first photo of his
two-year-old son he also to post a
picture of Sophie his son Adonis and he
sat on Lil Wayne's Young Money radio
show this weekend he wanted to finally
introduce them to the world it was great
for me you know it was great um
it was great to just you know share that
with the world and I just felt like it
wasn't even anything I talked to anybody
about anything I planned I just woke up
one morning and I was like you know what
this is just something that that I want
to do I want to be able to go places
with my my son and share memories with
my son I don't want to feel like just
because of a life choice I made to be
you know quote unquote celebrity that I
gotta like cuz I know make everybody
live under this place exactly yeah
so I I just wanted to free myself of
that and you know I've watched you be a
functioning wrap father for years an
incredible father you know and that gave
me a lot of confidence too a lot of us
like you know chains is a great father
and a lot of the guys that we came up
around you know just just being um just
being great like great family men on
those tours and on those long steps so
nice when albums need to get done but
specifically you you know just like just
how how you always just made maid
function and work and how much love you
know the people the people in your life
had for you and I could just tell the
way your kids would stare at you that
you know the time and effort that that
you put in as a father so that was
really inspiring for me just to note I
like you know I can still keep pushing
forward as a musician and be there for
my son very how he's uh giving kudos to
little Wayne and I think they may be
collaborating I think they kind of said
some of that yeah
so it's great that he was able to be
open about it on his podcast you know I
think being in isolation
you know Drake doesn't give a lot to the
media he's very quiet any time he seemed
on the carpet he rushes by and now while
he's in isolation we've seen the twosie
now he's talking about Donna's and he's
being more open about his own life which
has been very private and so now I think
he feels so much liberated and I think
one of the great things about isolation
is the reflection and I think that's
what's happened to him is that he's able
to celebrate what's most important to
him and that's as a family and his son
that's interesting when he talks about
you know seeing other rappers be fathers
yeah I can't think like you know a lot
of the guys are around let's say 15
years ago yeah I don't really you know
they didn't really have being a father
as part of their persona like I think if
Snoop Dogg even little Wayne like I
don't really know anything about his
kids but yeah like do you think we're
moving into a new era where it's okay to
be a dad in your public life like
Eminem's been more vocal about it
obviously Kanye doesn't hide his kids in
the kind of ways yeah I do think that
that perception is there that persona is
changing a little bit in the rap world
that you could you can be a father like
it always seemed like you always had to
be like the single guy you know what I
mean
but now it seems like you can be that
family man and still be a successful
rapper in the public eye yeah I think I
totally agree with you on this because I
think in the last two three years
there's just been this shift where
everyone wants more of openness to be
raw and real and actually let people
into what they believe and I think
that's partly what's with what's
happening on social media and people are
starting to talk about their own lives
and not closing up about and I think rap
music to it has been adjusting in
different ways and the way music is even
made in the rock world right and the
wordings and it's more I guess the word
is more sensitive to what they're
putting out there in terms of their
lyrics so to be open as a father I think
that kind of connects with his music as
well I think in creating new music and
being creative while being in isolation
in his mansion would be a great way for
him to kind of reflect as being a dad so
I think his music coming up is going to
be very different I think it's gonna be
more connected to who he is our boss
points at that chance the rapper
postponed his a tour earlier this year
to be this kid policies are still
something Drake I'm still not sure about
Austin's drink kind of fell off a bit
which is not true at all I mean he's
still you just released the mixtape on
Friday that was trending like crazy
Skippy says it's strange that the media
is so invested in his
but all we should care about is his
artistry yeah I mean that's the other
aspect like the whole idea we've talked
about this before in terms of
celebrities getting ahead of paparazzi
and putting photos out there so you know
Drake's whole thing was like you know I
wanted to put a foreword out there so I
can go out in public with my son I don't
need to worry about people think
pictures yeah I don't know if there was
a huge because he keeping it so hid we
didn't even know we necessarily had a
child right so do you think that was a
huge thing that Drake would have been
hounded or would have been I it's so
interesting because again I think it's
all this experience of being in
isolation he's been very open eyes I've
heard more from Drake now than I have
like we were talking about Cameron Diaz
there's this again there's this ability
to understand who he is and he wanted to
share it the fact is you're right we
should be focusing more on their
artistry rather than what their life is
all about but when you put it out in
social media it's a different
perspective and people want to know
because they're able to connect with him
in that way and I think we're intrigued
like that's Drake what who's been very
quiet and for him to open up this way
now we're more more intrigued to find a
who Drake really is and you know learn
more about his son and his life and you
know what it when he creates music he
has this ability to make people connect
to it and if it means his family life
then we're gonna ask the questions about
his family life that's the thing you
wonder if he's open up the floodgates a
little bit bye-bye posting the photos
and talking about it now because it has
been so quiet